viernes de economía y como cada semana
es momento para hablar de un tema en
específico ya profundidad buenas noches
para ustedes jorge por anoche angela y
vamos a iniciar el especial de economía
dedicado a la salida de la bancarrota de
puerto rico así es que esta semana se
completó ese proceso que representó
básicamente la mayor reestructuración de
deuda pública en eeuu y fue precisamente
hace siete años cuando puerto rico
declaró la bancarrota y dijo que no
estaba en capacidad de pagar una deuda
que entonces sumaba más de 70 mil
millones de dólares gracias a un plan de
ajuste la deuda consiguió una reducción
de cerca del 80 por ciento ahora la
deuda queda en unos 7 mil millones de
dólares mediante un intercambio de bonos
en el que los inversores entregan sus
títulos por nuevas obligaciones la isla
resolverá reclamos que rondan los mil
millones de dólares presentados por
residentes y empresas locales y también
va a emitir bonos por valor de más de 10
mil millones de dólares puerto rico
también va a restablecer hasta 1.300
millones de dólares tomados del sistema
público de pensiones la quiebra de
puerto rico- representó la más grande en
bonos municipales de la historia de eeuu
y para darnos una idea la isla pagó
cerca de mil millones de dólares en
honorarios a consultores y abogados
entre otros gastos durante este proceso
pero cómo fue que puerto rico pudo
declarar la bancarrota cómo fue ese
proceso conversamos antes con carlos
mercader él es ex representante del
gobierno de puerto rico entre la casa
blanca y el congreso de eeuu y esto nos
dijo puerto rico por ser un territorio
de eeuu no será un estado sino un
territorio puerto rico no estaba
amparado a las leyes de reestructuración
que están amparados los diferentes
estados de la nación por ejemplo hoy día
si fuéramos al estado de illinois que es
un estado que tiene una deuda pública
alta tiene un sistema de pensiones de
empleados comunas mentales altos
clint hoy tiene hoy día una ley que le
permite declarar quiebra de sus
instrumentalidades públicas y de sus
corporaciones públicas y de sus ciudades
puerto rico en 2016 no tenía esta ley no
podía declarar quiebra de nada y
entonces puerto rico va al congreso
y trabaja una legislación en el congreso
de eeuu que por ser un territorio quien
manda al final y al congreso de eeuu y
el congreso de eeuu crea una ley única
específica para puerto rico se llamó la
ley promesa esa ley creó básicamente una
una avenida para que puerto rico pudiera
dejar a la quiebra no como lo hacían los
estados que podían declarar que ahora su
instrumentalidades pública de sus
ciudades pero si no de su deuda general
estatal dentro de esa ley que menciona
el invitado se creó la famosa junta en
qué consistía bueno esta junta
prácticamente su trabajo era
reestructurar esa millonaria deuda de
puerto rico y muchas de sus decisiones
incluso estaban por encima del gobierno
local algo que generó el rechazo entre
muchos ciudadanos que argumentaban que
el comité o la junta era una imposición
de la casa blanca así y lo recordó
nuestro invitado si ahí entra un poquito
de estas controversias de
cuán
democrático realmente es esta imposición
cuan democrática realmente son las
decisiones que se van a estar tomando el
pueblo no necesariamente escogió a estas
personas para que estén allí más sin
embargo fueron fueron nombradas por
miembros del congreso por la casa blanca
y entonces puede velar es tras todo este
tipo de dinámicas realmente las
decisiones que toman tienen en
consideración el
bienestar de los puertorriqueños no la
tienen de a quién representan qué
intereses tienen en una dinámica de una
controversia muy aguda y yo digo que
todavía prevalente porque aún después de
cinco o seis años de establecido esto la
realidad del caso es que todavía es
controversial muchas de las decisiones
que tomas por ejemplo y fuera de la
reestructuración
el gobierno por ejemplo le pidió permiso
en estos días a utilizar un fondo de
emergencia para para utilizarlo y para
paliar lo que es el aumento en los
costos de las del gas y la junta de
supresión císcar adiós no lo vamos a así
que a ese nivel de decisión tiene la
junta supervisión fiscal todo lo que
tenga que ver con un gasto o que afecte
a la economía o el presupuesto la junta
tiene la última palabra y la voluntad
muy selecta la junta no la responde a
nadie del gobierno de puerto rico más
sin embargo vive con el fondo del dinero
del gobierno puerto rico angela esta
reducción de la deuda permite ahora a
puerto rico trabajar en mejorar su
economía mientras miles de millones de
dólares en fondos federales para
desastres ayudas para la pandemia y
reembolsos de seguros por huracanes
pueden llegar ahora a la isla las
autoridades se centran en impulsar el
turismo y aumentar la fabricación para
algunos analistas aunque la salida de la
bancarrota es un hecho a celebrar es
poco probable que la isla pueda acceder
pronto a los mercados financieros
internacionales porque todavía tiene que
poner al día sus estados financieros
auditados pues jorge el agradecimiento
para ustedes a nuestros televidentes el
siguen con nosotros ya volvemos
[Música]